une à une ses hautes tours se sont
dressés dans le ciel de paris
ces silhouettes insolites sont les
esquisses d'une cité d'affaires qui se
construit à la défense pour l'instant
l'ensemble des bâtiments ressemble à un
corps sans tête sur la partie la plus
haute
il n'existe en effet qu'un terrain vague
d'une dizaine d'hectares traversé par
une voie ferrée et par un grand
boulevard circulaire mais pas pour
longtemps
monsieur richard a pris une décision
deux immeubles 2 immense miroir de 60
mètres de hauteur vont s'y construire
l'auteur du projet fait un pari mettre
de la poésie dans un lieu consacré aux à
feu j'ai remarqué à odeillo je suis allé
dans le midi de miroirs solaires dans
les faits plastique était si puissant
qui nous semble être de nature à être
utilisé dans des architectures là bas
ils sont faits pour porter à quatre
mille degrés certaines point focal
ici il s'agit d'éviter ces choses-là
chose facile à faire est de conserver
l'image merveilleuse que ces miroirs à
odeillo faisait tout pays ce serait
d'offrir à la ville une double image
d'elle-même un miroir et blanc l'autre
noir ce que qu'on verra passer de l'un à
l'autre le nuage qui blanc est là
deviennent
hier première difficulté qu'il a fallu
résoudre l'equilibre trouver l'équilibré
entre ces gigantesques masses de béton
d'acier et de verre
deuxième difficulté la perspective de la
voie triomphale auxquelles les parisiens
sont très sensibles longue de 7 km elle
part de la cour carrée des tuileries
franchi le carrousel la concorde l'arc
de triomphe pour atteindre enfin le
parvis du cnit palais des expositions
avec le projet de monsieur ayo la
perspective s'y arrête
déjà deux fois une fois jusqu'à l'arc de
triomphe une seconde fois jusqu'à n'est
recommencerai une nouvelle courbe pour
aller ailleurs qu'une avenue ne doit pas
continuer sans fin doit avoir une fin
c'est la fin qui donne le caractère à
lunas venez la défense qui est encore qu
un immense chantier d'où s'échappent des
bâtiments terminée
la défense va donc voir s'ouvrir de
nouveaux travaux ils commenceront avant
la fin de l'année et ils se termineront
si tout va bien dans trois ans